pasamos a actualizar las noticias
económicas con Daniela Blandón aquí en
directo América Daniela otra vez el
saludo para usted Otra vez Buenos días
Ángela vamos a empezar hablando de estos
despidos en meta que se sumaron o se
sumarían previsiblemente a los miles de
despidos en Twitter si Ángela Esto es lo
que dice el periódico de Wall Street
journal es uno de los de mayor
circulación de Estados Unidos que cita
Fuentes familiarizadas con el asunto
concretamente dice que la matriz de las
redes sociales Facebook Instagram y
WhatsApp se está preparando para
notificar esta semana despidos masivos
en lo que sería la primera reducción
amplia de personal en sus 18 años de
historia y es que hasta septiembre meta
tenía 87 mil empleados pero sus
resultados financieros del trimestre
decepcionaron a Wall Street por ejemplo
Tuvo una caída en sus ingresos y sus
utilidades así como un aumento
en los gastos y también una estimación
de caja futura menor a la que espera el
mercado este fue su peor resultado desde
2019 y el cuarto trimestre consecutivo
de disminución de ganancias Daniela Cómo
se venía incluyendo en mi pregunta meta
no es la única tecnología que está en
crisis no y es que todas las
tecnológicas tuvieron un gran Boom en la
pandemia pero este año la situación ha
sido diferente los recortes de Facebook
o de meta que es la matriz se suman a
los de Twitter de la semana pasada que
afectaron Aproximadamente a la mitad del
personal más de 3000 trabajadores su
nuevo dueño y ceo Iron musk ha dicho que
reducir gastos y empezar a cobrar por
servicios es la única manera de que la
plataforma sea rentable ya que hoy
pierde unos 4 millones de dólares al día
precisamente el fin de semana
y los modos que estuvo dando algunas
pistas sobre el control de cuentas que
piensa ejercer en Twitter advirtió que
aquellas con nombres falsos es decir que
simulen otra identidad sin especificar
que son parodia serán definitivamente
suspendidas Y es que varias celebridades
con sello azul comenzaron a ponerse el
nombre de elon musk y a tuitear como
reacción a sus más recientes decisiones
pues mire esto ha sido polémico desde el
inicio con elon musk Así que veremos qué
más va sucediendo con esta red social
ahora en otros temas está a punto de
nacer una nueva disputa comercial entre
la Unión Europea y Estados Unidos por
cuenta de una decisión de Joe biden Sí
pues le voy a hablar primero de uno de
esos antecedentes de peleas comerciales
entre Estados Unidos y el bloque
comunitario la más reciente se agudizó
durante la administración de Donald
Trump cuando se impusieron aranceles de
lado y lado en el marco de la disputa de
larga Data por subsidios aeronáuticos
entre o los que se le otorgaron a ver
vas y a boing ha pasado más de un año de
tregua y los vientos de disputa vuelven
a soplar el lío tiene que ver con la ley
de reducción de inflación que ha sido
uno de los proyectos bandera de Joe
biden el ministro de finanzas francés
Bruno lemberg dijo en una entrevista
televisiva que deben decirles claramente
a sus socios estadounidenses que esta
ley es un problema importante para ellos
que no es aceptable y también que podría
crear un gran impacto en la industria
europea bien pero entonces cuál es el
motivo de preocupación específicamente
en Europa Ángela que la ley sancionada
en agosto otorga subvenciones Fiscales a
los fabricantes de vehículos por cada
componente producido en Estados Unidos
entre otros las Industrias europeas
temen que esto les quita inversiones
potenciales al continente Un ejemplo muy
claro que dio el ministro francés dijo
que lleva varios meses discutiendo con
una empresa del sector de vehículos
eléctricos potencialmente interesada en
instalarse en este país y que va a crear
unos 5000 empleos directos para ellos se
está proponiendo una ayuda de hasta mil
millones de euros El problema es que
Estados Unidos le está proponiendo 4 mil
millones de dólares las delegaciones de
ambas partes ya
negociaciones pero ya la comisión
europea amenazó con que podría llegar a
recurrir a la Organización Mundial del
Comercio y bueno hablando de comercio el
comercio exterior chino cayó en octubre
las exportaciones e importaciones del
gigante asiático se contrajeron
inesperadamente 0,3% en el primer caso
0,7% en el segundo caso en términos
interanuales es decir frente al mismo
periodo del año pasado en el caso de las
exportaciones Ha tenido un cambio brusco
porque habían crecido un 6% en
septiembre Esa es la primera caída
simultánea tanto de exportaciones como
importaciones desde mayo de 2020 en
pleno inicio de la pandemia del covid 19
y afecta a todo el mundo porque china es
un gran consumidor de materias primas y
también un enorme exportador de
manufacturas toda esta situación está
afectando también a un proveedor de
Apple que espera retrasos en las
entregas de modelos iPhone 14
está la del proveedor Apple foxcom que
emplea unas 200.000 personas y que está
bajo confinamiento hasta el próximo 9 de
noviembre
Pues bien Daniela Gracias por la
actualización noticiosa de economía y ya
puede descansar por hoy sí señora por lo
menos hasta el martes mañana nos vemos
muy bien y es el momento ahora de irnos
para París en directo